las mesas de votación aquí en el lycée
français charles de gaulle uno de los
principales puntos de votación abrieron
a las 8 de la mañana hora local y
estarán abiertas hasta las 7 de la noche
hora del reino unido- con las personas
que hemos hablado aseguran que la
jornada ha sido muy rápida muy sencilla
que ha estado muy bien organizada esta
segunda vuelta presidencial y que de
hecho votar les ha tomado máximo dos
minutos y como ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas cada vez llegan más y más
personas que quieren votar en este punto
que es uno de los siete habilitados en
la capital británica para un total de 16
en todo el reino unido se han fijado
mesas de votación en las principales
ciudades del país como edimburgo como en
belfast y otras ciudades principales de
inglaterrra aquí en londres están
habilitadas para votar 111 mil
ciudadanos franceses lo que nos muestra
que la gran población de franceses vive
aquí en la capital británica para un
total además de 116 mil ciudadanos
franceses
se espera en esta elección aquí en el
reino unido- por supuesto la segunda
vuelta presidencial en francia es una de
las noticias más importantes a esta hora
en los medios británicos dada la
importancia de las relaciones anglo
francesas pero también porque francia es
uno de los grandes aliados del reino
unido- no solamente en europa en la otan
sino también en el g7